can we hug for camera
let me look at the camera of course yeah
this is what this is
this is
missing everyone who doesn't understand
this bit is going to be like what is
this
this is for koi
i'll see you coy
[Applause]
[Music]
are we on
all right guys we got our first
celebrity this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
koi's on the other side of the carpet
today over here there's a barrier
between us and it feels strange how does
it feel to be better than us today well
today and today alone it feels great
it's a one-time thing with the million
subscriber channel when you're on the
other side of the carpet feeling just we
put you right here i feel good about it
yeah look at me look being right there
how's it feel on this side without me
i'm usually i'm usually there with you
we're you're the only one we're going to
talk to today i hope you get good
content i hope you get it for me i mean
it's a good warm up this is how the
interview day starts yeah so i was just
messing around with koi as i was waiting
for the cast and crew for prey to arrive
and then uh all of a sudden this started
happening
oh my god this is happening here
we are now we made it to l.a we did it
look at us
who would have thought who would have
thought hello hi jack channel
we've covered the boys we're massive
massive fans of the boys first of all
derek robertson we love you yes derek if
you're watching this
hello and i love you can i ask this
huey is actually known to be so good at
like defeating soups while just being
the average human do you think he could
actually take down a predator no
i'm going to go ahead and say no i think
he's he's ill-equipped for for anything
sci-fi to the like superheroes sure i
think aliens like aliens that are
designed for hunting you no i don't
think he can do it do you think i think
maybe you on v
maybe mian v maybe
you and your comic book counterpart on v
like
like make it a willy wonka element yeah
sure sure so so so we huey yeah and then
huey campbell who can teleport exactly
while naked and up against the predator
i'm down and the homelander strength we
huey like yeah as he evolves like sure
i'm down i'm down i've heard you talk
about wanting to be in star wars and
such and um you know you're just in the
screen movie as well if you were to be
in a predator movie do you think that
you would want to be in a period piece
like this or would you want to do like a
modern day follow-up honestly i'll take
what i can get uh dan trachtenberg you
have my number uh uh let's make this
happen
okay your character in rampage versus
how you'd react in this
oh man my character rampage is he's that
guy's a piece of [ __ ] uh i'm gonna go
ahead and say he loses whatever battle
okay i think his name is connor
yeah
[ __ ] that guy let's ask you something oh
yeah i'm over here do you think you
could uh handle the predator i think i
would find a way to be like i'd have
ingenuity like i feel like i'd survive
better in a stakes that are this high
than like in nature like if the world
ended i'd die out of apathy if you and
the predator had to somehow find uh food
uh at the gaslight district yeah
district in san diego would we find
fries cause that's the situation you and
i have been in uh i would say before 2
am yes before 2 a.m 205 am certainly
certainly hell no did you know it's a
food desert at 207 it actually is that
was a joke that was very did you succeed
after we left this is just for us no i
wound up going to an ihop uh at like
maybe three in the morning matt and i
found no whiskey yeah but we did find
like a series of hotels that looked at
us like we were drunk already and
weren't so we had the whole journey
they're just like comic-con man always
brings in the crazies always brings up
that night was magic other than the
hunger yeah i don't think even predator
could find food i don't i think we'd be
the food by default yeah it was almost
cannibalism like this almost happened
absolutely totally a thing now he would
find food
and we were good and we were tired yeah
now i i want to know with the way things
escalated uh we just got a bunch of
announcements with the the new show like
generation v oh yeah someone that loves
the world are you excited to like have a
new thing to watch yeah uh actually i
can i think i can actually say this now
um because i was we just announced that
i was in toronto recently shooting uh
star trek strange new worlds and while i
was there i got to be there when the new
cast was coming in so i took them all
out to a brunch and they're all like
such incredible people and such
incredible actors and i i cannot wait to
watch that show i think they're all
going to absolutely crush it like
seriously i know how much you love it
like authentically so it's cool that
you'll get to see dailies without you
like you'll get to oh i don't i don't
think they're showing me dailies but i'm
very excited to watch the show just as a
genuine fan i really am derek we love
you i'm gonna let this guy i'm glad to
be a boom guy today this is great work
right excellent well done well done
everything right thank you jack thank
you thank you thank you koi all right we
don't need to do anything else
roll the camera
it's [ __ ] choose your come on man not
freaking out over me i freaked out over
you guys for years that's weird this is
really weird i'm stressing out juju
are we [ __ ] filming yeah we're
feeling
the sweats are we feeling
what's happening
are we praying oh my god juju i'm so
sorry we're so
unprofessional okay
i'm so so unprofessional judy what what
do you want to be asked
i don't know i was like saying like
that's like somebody asked you how are
you for the first time after you've been
struggling you're like
what yeah i'm gonna ask you just general
questions like what do you want to be at
oh my gosh how's your day my day's going
fine man i'm here with you it's actually
like old people are we on oh we've been
on this whole time we've been oh snap
this entire time
guys we've met many times he's one of
koi's closest friends i compete with koi
to be yours
i know thank you that's what i was
writing i was selling himself short
right there right there you can't do
that you saw me hooking for that answer
i'm going to test our friendship right
now
come on my first question juju would you
ever come on the real rejects channel
absolutely when you want it that's what
you got to do you got to get them on
camera saying yes to [ __ ] yes how you
doing this is the covenant the contract
it's all it's out there now so i can't i
can't back out well actually are you a
predator fan are you a fan of this
franchise predator is the first predator
is one of my favorite movies of all time
predator is my favorite movie monster of
all time
yeah i just i've always wanted to see it
like get back to the original like it's
never been as
great the closest we got was predators i
feel like i thought that was pretty cool
but the fact that we're getting like a
period piece
female led it it looks amazing i can't i
can't wait to see this one
transition so how many followers get on
tick tock now did you like count every
i don't count luckily i could just look
at it and say like okay 3.1 it's still
it's still there 3.1 million 1 000 1000
3.1 thousand thousand three point one
thousand i cancelled you this morning
and uh i made sure you lost
but seriously i'd love for you to
actually come on the channel i i imagine
koi's going to be like no it's got to be
me and coy but come on we got to like
boot him out come on man like i would
love to come on come on the channel like
i'm surprised you haven't asked me i'm
kind of offended actually you know i
know you i know koi i just said we were
friends what's the deal man you don't
like me
i have i have reached my family
childhood trauma right every time i see
these guys making theories i sit there
like a kid in the window watching the
kids play in the snow like
i want to join
someone please and they're just talking
away that koi tells me about it i'm just
like well okay i'll just i'm not gonna
ask i'm gonna just let you ask me and
you did it on camera so good you know
what i've decided is that for the prey
premiere we're gonna make you on the
thumbnail we're just gonna yeah we'll
just have you choose you yes use the
space is juju the sardines the thumbnail
the moment you found out he's gonna be
the thumbnail is the thumbnail
that's so better i'm so with it that
should be the that's our opening of the
video right there all right man well
thank you for your time juju
i hope you know that
i like you more than koi generally
i told you we're fighting for the
attention and we're going to beat our
koi who i'm going to beat out i'm gonna
walk up to koi with this goofy ass smile
on my face like cool yeah i know
something you don't know
you just made me so happy right now
even if you're lying i'm just like the
fact that you said it out loud on camera
i'll have that actually there is
something i do want to ask you for real
super sarcastic comments we've asked
this whole time
at the oscars was there someone you met
that you were like your heart started
beating or you started blinking when you
were talking to them
you know what
i can't recall
however i will say that
jamie lee curtis and i talking about one
piece wow it's like the single greatest
moment of my life nice it really was
like the fact like i was just in my head
the whole time like is this happening
are we really doing this my
grandmother's gonna freak out you know
now now i got some clout with my
grandmother because i talked to her
about it all the time and i'm just like
jamie lee loves it i know her now she's
jamie leading me
so i got a little bit of clout with the
grandmother now so that helped me out a
lot it helped my career all family hood
traumas solved that day right there i
saw it that day so one piece saves
family trauma i'm just saying well thank
you juju for your time uh let coin know
that he's been booted out right david
i know nothing
no one will ever meet david no he'll
ever meet right here
the entire time the entire time all
right can we hug for camera
let me look at the camera
yeah this is what this is rick this is
missing everyone who doesn't understand
this bit is going to be like what is
this
this is for koi
i'll see you koi
[Applause]
[Music]